ciao la mia vendetta più grande è stata
quando il mio miglior amico e ha tradito
ed è andato con la mia fidanzata quindi
tutti e due dei grandissimi stimoli e io
ho mandato a casa sua un pacco di no ma
certamente ha mandato un pacco con della
cacca di elefante all'interno tramite il
sito che si chiama sciita express e alla
modica cifra di 15 euro mi sono
vendicato con della nota la scelta
versamento era grosso questo pacco 15
euro 15 euro di mancata la antica che
senso che non sapevano poste di elefante
c'era proprio la foto dell'ex perché
c'era la foto del fante che aveva fatto
così anche se la mii pollici ciao
ragazzi bentornati una nuova puntata di
vita buttata a questo il mio canale la
scorsa settimana gli ho chiesto un
favore di farmi sapere quali sarebbero
stati i temi che avreste voluto vedere
sono reati un sacco di messaggi
ho controllato quelli che sono stati i
più votati e tra questi ne subito notato
uno quindi alla fine rullo di tamburi il
tema della puntata di oggi sarà vendette
ringrazio ancora giù ligi per questo
suggerimento non so come abbia fatto a
esserci aver prima ma sono contento che
ci sia arrivata tu comunque per parlare
di un tema così succulento ho pensato di
invitare all'interno degli studios de
casa mia una persona che so essere una
professionista una ragazza che è già
stata ospite di questa rubrica niente
popodimeno di claudia genolini claudia
che emoziona ma io sono molto felice di
essere qui soprattutto che questo tema
ne abbiamo cambiati dico 20 oggi
parleremo di brufoli giardinaggio sai se
avessi perfetto sono molto curiosa di
sapere i messaggi una molto curiosa di
sapere che cosa che hanno mandato in
amore è più oppure guarda io sono
contento che sarà il e troverei pendere
to the sea che cos'è che ti nero per me
li troverò in pelle per il giorno 6
pronta partiamo una volta mia nipote di
13 anni
ha risposto male quindi per menti
karmiel al in deciso di metterle un
pollo morto spennato sul letto mentre
l'era quasi addormentata meglio non
entrata in camera sua ma cosa tipo la
testa del cavallo nel letto di un passo
da tante che il primo magari l'ordina
donte nei voli morbida vendetta abbiamo
il nostro jack per un effetto ottimale
urlare il canone rai
il lancio ciao la vendetta più grande
l'ho fatta al mio ex fidanzato un giorno
scoperto che mi tradiva ho scoperto
tramite delle chat dove c'erano anche
delle foto di lui e si fotografa va al
suo pene non era manco vanta bile come
cosa perché lo fa un pene veramente
bravi loro ha avuto la brillante idea di
stampare centinaia e centinaia e
centinaia di foto e lasciarli in giro
per tutta la città dovesse aprire un
canale che si chiama vendette e farlo
indica fare un business vendette punto
risale ha creato il sito della cacca ai
stata lei a lei una casa in campagna con
lei polli morti
lei dietro di genio da vendetta migliori
kiyomi siamo il peso è stata con un mio
ex fidanzato che meno lasciato in una
maniera veramente aberrante con un
messaggio sul cellulare e questo
biglietto me la sono presa qualche anno
dopo quando la sua fidanzata gli ha
fatto le corna con me è arrivato
all'improvviso non sono pronto anche lei
si è vendicata ex amica nell'altra lei
dice lei e quell'altra aiuto come sono
le mie due nuove migliori amiche
cercherò
il professore ha capito ha bisogno di
amici e divenne tristi quando avevo sei
anni
mia sorella ne aveva 41 bambina da vivo
tanti pupazzi e in particolare un look
che era un panna qui ero molto
affezionato
buongiorno mia sorella cda hanno
normalmente come si fa con l lei decide
bene di prendere il mio faccio preferito
prendere un coltello e con chiamarlo
questo dice tutto
io per vendetta sulla sorellina avrei
preso il mio bamba avrei tolto tutto il
cotone ci aveva messo dentro la sala è
adesso sarei per sempre un po non ha
cucito e la tribù ribattezzata giovanna
è morta tu adesso se il cor a morat una
famiglia di persone smaltire fisco
collabora voglioso intenti sono pari
versetti magra mar
k ma voi invece e tu ti sei mai indicato
di qualcuno no allora devo essere io se
lascio il mio primo ragazzo e il suo
amico concerto molto un giorno vi fa per
ridere un pochino beccato guglielmo su
un sito nel quale si trattava per
conoscere l'anima gemella mai funzionato
che ci faceva lì e gliel'ho detto
pensando che un altissimo grado di
insieme a per lo scoperto impazzisco
perché lo trovo un gesto infantile e
quindi gli scrive direttamente gli dico
senti un po io sono single
quindi posso fare ciò che mi pare la
domanda quindi è che cosa ci fa una
persona fidanzata come sei tu su un sito
di questo tipo e 24 ore per dirlo al tuo
ragazzo
altrimenti glielo dico io come lo sai la
faccia dopo ventiquattr'ore non gliel'ha
detto e io che l'ho detto ragazzo ho
suggerito comunque ragazzo di rimanere
insieme a lui perché era una bravata
stupida toglie rubato il ragazzo
[Risate]
sembrava che chi non se li è invece ma
che derivati sono lasciati con chi fare
ma bene ne ha fatte di quanti gli crude
una vendetta è fatta
è vero in quanto ho scoperto gli appunto
lui aveva avuto di rapporti di suonare
una missione nel posto di lavoro e
quindi non potevo farlo il che spacciava
droga prendere il posto di lavoro e
anche libri e gli estensi di contatto
con la vediamo in sala mentre menaio e
l'amore di tutta precario e il vis
essenziale basso più narcos
ma spacciava e faceva sesso prendi
avvenivano sacrifici umani sgozzavano
galli neri inneggiando a satana e
giorgio beta che ho mai messo in atto e
70 contro mia madre per vendicarmi del
fatto che aveva buttato due scatoloni di
cose dalla mia camera perché diceva che
era sempre disordinata e che buttava
sempre troppo poche cose che per
vendetta o piazzato un topo di gomma
avendole una paura matta di topi nelle
marce della macchina c'è stato solo un
problema mia madre non si è accorta del
ratto vicino alle marce è andata a fare
le sue commissioni si accorge il solo in
strada della presenza del topo questa
l'ha fatta andare contro un palo che gli
ai lati delle strade però la cosa è che
anche dopo aver capito che era un topo
di qom non riusciva a toglierlo e ha
dovuto aspettare il carro attrezzi
io non so dire se bill e non tra i
pedali nostre le marce
hai capito se pedali è capito le ho
tolto il freno
lo chiedo altro terreno non fa ad andare
a che si impari a buttare i miei
scatoloni funerale con quel tocco di
gomma e presente quando nei film
americani lancio di philogen invece il
topo di fogna gli ha tirato le scatole
questi livelli ha buttato impare avevo
circa 14 anni
mia sorella giorno a casa con la madre
con una nuova lei mi fanno fare appunto
questa cosa mi prende in giro inizia a
ridere io praticamente le do un pugno al
seggio della festa e
nominare dal naso tv ma ricevono per
l'estrazione del gergo e ora è figlia
unica accorto che non c'era praticamente
insistito di protezione è presente gli
ordini è un caso ben integrato ma quello
che pensa ecco la fine ci penso io
tradotte maniere possibili viva e 6
gradi
diciamo che pensa la boxe neanche
iniziato ad attaccare cosa sono il chino
certo tipo di polso chi è scatto capito
una cosa una clamorosa è veramente
sfilare aree pic del carriera che
scrivono per chi oddio che sputano
insomma che sta solo da sola nonostante
stato un dettaglio ero con loro ragazzi
e sorella si disattiva si lottava ha
scoraggiato i fan certamente io ero sul
successo una volta aveva esagerato
l'appunto scoraggiata una roba un po ma
nucleari che quasi per vomitare momento
ho preso un pezzo di accesso sono andato
di casa che condivideva mahler e la
parte super letto castello
brusco stessi fiorino che io lo faccia
lei posta in gioco